[Music]
[Applause]
and Chris Mannix covers the NBA he's a
senior reporter writer for Sports
Illustrated and uh let me get your
thoughts on the Bradley Beal trade from
Phoenix's perspective
on the surface
you get a player the caliber of Bradley
Beal
by
giving up as little as they did you
would have to declare this a win
um
you know Bradley Beal even though he's
only played what 90 games over the last
two years when he's right is still a
25-ish point per game score so
you get that from Phoenix's perspective
but when you start really looking at the
fit
there are some red flags there uh
Phoenix now has a team that is led by
three guys that like the mid-range jump
shot you look at the number of mid-range
jump shots Bill Devin Booker and Kevin
Durant uh shoot and it's a lot uh
they're effective scores but they do
shoot a lot of mid-range jump shots and
you start to wonder if
Beale and Devin Booker are
somewhat repetitive if they overlap with
their skill set so you're not exactly
sure how they fit and you also look at
this deal and you are now if you're
Phoenix you're now all in with this
group like there's nobody I mean Devin
Booker you could trade down the line
because young enough and and people want
him but
you're not going to be able to trade
Bradley Beal who's no trade clause comes
with him to Phoenix
um Kevin Durant certainly could still be
movable but not for anywhere near the
yield that that they gave up to to get
him uh this is your team for at least
the next three or four years uh and
you're you're all in there's there's
almost no way you can
substantially improve this group uh
because you don't have draft picks and
you don't have any kind of cap
flexibility that flexibility is going to
go down in the years to come because the
NBA as you know is going to make it is
making it a lot harder for teams to just
free spend their way to success so
it's it's a deal that you know on paper
you argue makes the sons better but
I I don't look at them as being better
than Denver right now and that that for
the next couple of years is going to be
the bar in the Western Conference yeah I
was curious about this that you just
added another scorer they still have
DeAndre eight and they don't have depth
and you have a lot of guys who do the
same thing they don't have Defenders
there and you're facing a team and I use
uh you know I capitalize team with
Denver that's a better all-around team I
don't know where Phoenix fits in now if
we you know let's Golden State are they
better than Golden State are they better
than the Lakers are they better than
Memphis
I'm not I'm not quite sure did they
improve their team
it looks different it looks different
looks sexy but I don't know I don't know
if they improve that much
I think they improved in part because it
was more likely than not that Chris Paul
wasn't going to be on the team anyway at
the start of next season Landry shambit
is a decent rotation player but you give
up uh seventh or eighth man to get a guy
like Bradley Beal they didn't have to
include a first round pick largely
because they don't have first round
picks so a collection of seconds is not
a steep price to play to pay for Bradley
Beal but look I said I don't think
they're better than Denver you can make
the argument that if the Warriors bring
that band back they're lesser than the
Warriors they're lesser than the
Sacramento Kings right now who I think
will take a step forward uh next year
and look when you're assessing Phoenix
we're doing it right now assuming
everything goes right health-wise that
these guys will be on the floor for 60
65 games together
it's just as likely that doesn't happen
I mean beale's got his own history of
injuries over the last four years has
not played more than 60 games in any of
those Seasons Kevin Durant we know his
injury history Devin Booker had an
injury last year that kept him out of
the lineup for a chunk of time so you're
committing 100 really 100 plus million
dollars to these three guys who may or
may not be able to play the entirety of
a season now you mentioned DeAndre
Hayden that's the guy teams are watching
over the next few days uh I don't think
that Phoenix can get equal value back in
return for DeAndre Aiden but they might
be able to flip him for a couple of role
players you know the kind of guys that
would flesh out the roster and give them
a little bit more depth which they're
sorely lacking at the moment it would be
tough like Frank Vogel has told me like
he wants to coach DeAndre Aiden if you
look at Frank vogel's teams that have
had the most success they have been
anchored by a defensive-minded big you
know whether that's Roy Hibbert in
Indiana and Anthony Davis Dwight Howard
during the championship season in Los
Angeles you know Frank has a defensive
strategy that kind of requires a player
like DeAndre Aiden but if the Suns can
find a deal that would net them two or
three valuable role players that's a
deal I think they'd strongly consider
now Washington side of this it just
feels like there's certain teams that
are feeder teams to make other teams
better Washington I think went down that
road with Bradley Beal and they were
basically stuck nobody cares about that
franchise no there's no relevancy with
them
um you know it's like Charlotte Orlando
where it's like hey we got a good player
and we're gonna let him go so what's the
future of the Washington Wizards
I can't think of a more
catastrophic finish to an Era for a
quote-unquote star player than than
Bradley Beal I mean
they extended him or they gave him a new
contract when everyone knew this was
going to happen like the idea that
Bradley Beal Kyle kuzma and Christos
porzingis was going to be able to
contend for anything was was just insane
I mean everybody knew it at the time but
the Wizards for some reason were just so
hell-bent on becoming a playoff team
just a playoff team that they're willing
to give Bradley Beal 250 million and a
no trade clause
to get him to stick around uh and then
they go out and swing a deal and look
Michael Winger the new top executive
there
he knew what the score was he knew they
had to move on from Bradley Beale and we
all knew Dan that the price for Bradley
Beal was going to be pretty low you know
for all the reasons we mentioned the
contract the no trade clause uh the fact
that he has not looked like the same
player over the last couple of Seasons
that he was in that 2021 year where he
averaged 30 plus points per game uh all
that said
they gave him away like they gave him
away you know what they got out of this
deal was getting off that contract and
that made me wonder like
was it absolutely necessary to deal
Bradley Beal right now like they didn't
get a first round pick back so it's not
like the draft was you know this this
deadline that they had for him
um to me I I thought maybe it would have
been better to kind of play this thing
out over the next couple of months and
maybe even play this thing out into next
season to see if the Market opens up a
little bit more and to see if Bradley
Beal because of a desire to get out of
Washington would have expanded his list
of teams that he'd be willing to go to I
mean over the last couple of weeks the
Wizards have been dealing like with
basically four teams maybe five who
Bradley Beal would have considered
waving his no trade clause you go into
next season and maybe Brad looking
around going
like I want to win something
this team might give me an opportunity
let's add that team to the list or let's
add that in the list because right now
the only thing Washington got for
Bradley Beal really tangibly was the
flexibility that comes with getting off
uh the final four years of that contract
and then Chris Paul it's probably I
don't I don't think he's buying in
Washington DC I'm good no he guess he
doesn't even get to Washington D.C well
yes
um there's going to be a lot of pressure
look the reason this deal is not
official is because right now Washington
Phoenix are looking for that third team
to facilitate Chris Paul they're seeing
if it's out there I don't know that it
is it's complicated because of Chris
Paul's salary there are certainly teams
that want him do they want him at the
30-ish million dollars that he'd be due
to be paid next year I don't know if
there's an answer to that question but
that's why this deal is still in in kind
of the the the the the stages where it's
not officially done yet
um
if it they can't find a third team and
this becomes a two-team deal there will
be pressure on the Wizards to just wave
Chris Paul uh I think that would be a
mistake because
if they wave Chris Paul
what do they gain from that like saving
a few extra bucks because you don't have
to give him the full amount of his
contract does that really matter to Ted
leonsis at this stage uh Chris Paul will
want the freedom to choose a contender
to go to this summer I don't blame him
for that but if I'm Washington
why not bring into training camp why not
you know bring him into the start of
next season for the exact same reasons I
said the wizard should have considered
bringing Bradley Beal back what do you
have to lose like you bring him in maybe
he comes in phenomenal shape maybe helps
you win a few games in the first six
weeks of the season and then maybe a
team's out there that goes wow Chris
Paul can still play let's give you a
protected first round pick for him and a
couple of expiring contracts to get you
there I just don't see the upside for
Washington
in in just letting Chris Paul go I mean
I understand that teams like to do this
to show their player friendly to show
that we'll work with you in situations
like this but
how often does that benefit teams in the
long term I mean I I think Washington's
got to be looking out for Washington in
this situation and if they think that
bringing Chris Paul to Camp might be
able to get them an asset in December or
January they should do it talking to
Chris manik Sports Illustrated senior
NBA writer I'll leave you with this what
are the chances Victor one by Yama isn't
great
I mean
.0001 I I would say it you know I I've
got a chance to watch a lot of his games
this year on the NBA app and and by the
way full credit to what Victor win by
Yama in a basketball Prospect landscape
where guys play as few games as possible
before they go into the NBA draft Victor
one manama's out there like last week
you know competing at the highest level
in his League
um
there's nothing he can't do that there's
I mean he's not a high percentage
three-point shooter just yet but he's a
teenager who already shoots high 20s
from three and you know is going to
develop that part of his game uh and
it's gonna grow significantly over the
next couple of years
um I I just think within two or three
years we're going to be looking at a
highly effective two-way player and
within three to five years we might be
looking at the most dominant player in
the NBA I just think his skill set is
that diverse and
his ability to grow like the just the
the parts of his game that can still
develop uh I think he's just gonna be
really special
thank you Chris
you got it Dan that's Chris Mannix
senior writer for Sports Illustrated